[inaudible]
I'm Richard Generous, uh, for those of
you don't know me, head of news at Google,
but that's not what
we're here about today.
We're here to talk about
Hollywood and is fascinated,
is sometimes folks are
with the tech sector. Uh,
we know people are even more fascinated
with Hollywood and, and we are too.
We share that. So I'm really
delighted to have you both here today.
So when we first said, just start by
having, by, by giving a bit of background,
first of all, Michael,
Michael Stuhlbarg, um, you,
you're one of those phenomenally talented
actors who I, who I sort of feel that,
that many of us may not know,
but we do know in the sense that you,
you so immerse yourself in your roles,
that you lose your own personal identity.
Um, which is I think, a
remarkable, truly remarkable thing.
Uh, but for those who
aren't as familiar, just,
I'll just mention a few of
the highlights, uh, that,
that quietly vicious
mob boss, uh, you know,
Arnold Rothstein and
boardwalk empire. Uh, the,
the hauntingly trouble Larry,
uh,
Gopnik and the in the Cohen
brothers movie a, a serious man. Um,
and then more recently, uh,
someone I know you portrayed, uh,
the Mac programming genius,
a Andy Hertzfeld in Steve Jobs.
Uh, uh, look forward to getting
some perspective on that.
And of course in Trumbo,
the,
that deeply conflicted and key role
of the actor Edward G. Robinson.
So, uh, thank you for being with us today.
Glad you can join us. And then we
get to Jay Roach, Jay Roach is by,
by many accounts, uh, the
nicest men in Hollywood. Um,
and, and interestingly, you
have not let that hold you back.
It's not stopped, can be, uh,
a kind of left handed compliment you,
you know,
you don't necessarily get a,
get a lot of respect instantly when that's
the first thing people say about you.
But, but I'll take it. I like
people and you know, I'm glad,
I'm glad that that comes across
well in it, in it does come across
and no,
it's not stopped you from becoming a
extraordinarily successful as a director,
uh, with many films across
many genres. Uh, uh,
you have course the tremendous commercial
success with the Austin Powers movies
with meet the parents, meet
the Fockers, uh, you also,
which many folks might know
produced the, uh, two of those,
a outrageous Sasha Baron Cohen,
uh, films, uh, Barat and,
and Bruno. Um, very
interesting shift there.
And in the last several years,
you've,
you've directed a number of more political
films with a recount about the Bush
corps, uh, presidential election, uh,
game change about John and,
and the intimate Sarah Pailin and
you're just finishing shooting. Uh,
is it recalled Lyndon Baines Johnson the
stage play Lbj on her way all the way
into a film. Um, and of course, uh,
what we're here to talk about today,
uh, with, with Trumbo. And by the way,
if this guy doesn't need an
additional coolness factor,
he's been married over 20 years
to a bangle, Susanna Hoffs,
that's probably the best,
the more, you know, tables at restaurants
than anything else. It's my wife.
Exactly. So, um, but today we're
going to talk about uh, about Trumbo.
Uh,
your film about Dalton Trumbo,
the legendary screenwriter who in the
face of the communist witch hunts of the
forties and 50s,
became a true American hero in his
efforts to defend the first amendment and
free expression. So, uh, obviously
we'll, we'll talk a lot about that.
One bit of disclosure before we begin
from my end is that I should come clean on
is at 35 years ago, I was, uh,
usually fortunate enough to convince a,
an amazing woman by the name of
Mitzi Trumbo, uh, to marry me. Um,
and her dad of course is,
is Dalton Trumbo.
And over the years I got federally
immersed in the close knit families
challenge, uh, with the blacklist
years and a challenge. It was, I mean,
mid to the age of eight was,
was kicked out of these junior girl scouts
called the blue birds because her dad
was a, was a commie. I mean, it was,
it was real stuff and challenging
stuff and hurtful stuff. Um,
and over the last two years,
I've had the great pleasure to get to
know you and many members of the cast in
the making of this film. So, but
let's get to the meat of this. Uh, uh,
why don't you introduce the
story of, of Trumbo, um, and,
and as you're doing,
so give us a sense of why you felt it was
important to make the movie. Yeah, sure.
Uh,
the,
the kind of a one paragraph Hook that
got me was Dalton Trumbo was one of the
most successful mainstream
screenwriters in Hollywood, uh,
in 1947,
um,
and was suddenly deemed a threat.
Uh,
an enemy of the state called
subpoenaed to testify, um,
decides he won't testify and won't
answer the questions about what political
affiliations do you have, who are
your friends that might have, uh,
some kind of ties to, to a
leftist organizations. And he,
by refusing is charged with contempt
of Congress and goes to jail,
immediately gets blacklisted
by the studios who all
agreed that anybody who was
part of the Hollywood 10
would have to be fired. Uh,
and the blacklist began based on
these 10 men who were called up.
He though, instead of succumbing, uh,
writes screenplays for the next
13 years under other names, uh,
and encourages other writers
to do the same thing.
Ends up winning two Academy Awards
for two beautiful movies, uh,
Roman holiday and the brave
on and then write Spartacus.
And which by suddenly are
finally being named, uh,
you know, the back of the
blacklist kind of dissolves.
Otto Preminger announces that
he's gonna put his name on a,
Trump has name on exodus and Kirk
Douglas puts his name on Spartacus.
And in a way, the spell is broken
by, by just writing. You know,
they,
that just by writing great screenplays
he gets and the other writers doing the
same thing,
it,
it exposes the blacklist for being just
not only lunacy and unfair and unjust,
but also completely ineffective,
didn't accomplish anything. And, uh,
and he kind of throws water on
the wicked witch, you know, um,
in this case played by Helen Mirin,
uh, Hedda hopper, the, uh, the,
the infamous gossip columnists.
So that's a little more than a paragraph,
but that's, that was the hook for me. I
was like, oh my God, how did this happen?
I can't believe this
happened. And, uh, you know,
how I'd like to find out everything,
everything I can about this story.
Um,
and to figure out what it had to
do with today too. That was a big,
a big part of it for me as well.
You know, interestingly, um, as, as,
as you know, when he testified,
uh, he and the Hollywood 10, uh,
did not, as others did plead
the fifth amendment, which says,
I will not incriminate myself. They
pleaded the First Amendment right, uh,
based on their belief that they had the
right to express themselves and to think
your thoughts without government
questioning. Um, as you know, um,
uh, yes, held in contempt,
found guilty and the supreme court
upheld that a conviction, well,
basically by re, by choosing because
they, there was a liberal majority, uh,
at the time they started this process and
they thought the first amendment would
get them through it.
And even if it didn't that eventually
the Supreme Court would throw it all out
as being ridiculous,
but,
but then to liberal justices
died within a month and a,
and so the supreme court, by refusing
to hear the appellate decision,
essentially a validated it and,
and the, uh, the conviction stood.
Yeah, it was a pretty, it's an
amazing, uh, it's an amazing, um,
predicament these guys kind of put
themselves into, in a way they,
they were so a progressive and
thoughtful and, and, and, uh,
defensive of certain, like
union, you know, issues.
They were very antifascist and somehow
they kind of became targets because,
uh, people who wanted to calls, you know,
people unamerican who were a
little more progressive, uh,
succeeded in exploiting the fears and
just went after. And by the way, writers,
nine of the 10 of them were writers
who were always the first ones that get
thrown under the bus in Hollywood.
Um, so, uh, it was, uh, yeah,
it was an interesting that,
that decision,
we portray that decision to choose the
first amendment over the fifth, uh,
and just, uh, to, to actually,
they decided very carefully to answer
the questions, answer all the questions,
but in their own way,
which meant a kind of interesting
circuitous way back to always.
You really don't have any right to be
asking this. I'll answer in my own way,
but I'm just going to keep reminding.
You have no right to ask me about my union
affiliation, my political affiliation,
or who my friends are who might
have similar affiliations. Exactly.
So
as we know of that period,
a lot of folks were forced
in a very difficult position.
So let's let Michael, let's look
at your role in Trumbo. You,
you play the, the acting legend
and Edward G. Robinson, uh,
the gangster of all gangsters that
were, um, and, and Robinson well,
deeply opposed to the committee's
efforts. Uh, and, and,
and certainly had his,
his political leanings were,
were far more left than not.
In the end,
he eventually named names. Um,
you know, it's a complex role.
It's the role in a sense.
It's the position that none of us wants
to ever be in of having to make those
kinds of decisions. In fact,
as, as Trumbo once said,
after the blacklist period,
there were no heroes.
There were only victims because everyone
was ultimately forced to do things they
would not have otherwise done.
So from your perspective,
uh, you know, and sort of what
made you take this role and, and,
and how did you approach it,
that level of complexity?
Um,
well,
Jay presented me with the opportunity and
we sat down and had a meal and chatted
about the prospect of it.
I was just coming off of about four
years of working on boardwalk empire in
playing someone who was
renowned as a kind of gangster.
And I was a little concerned that maybe
I would be taking on something too
similar, uh, with the life
of Edward Robinson. But I,
I had started looking up
information about him and, uh,
they couldn't have been more different
except the fact that they lived at a
certain time. And that, uh,
Mr. Robinson for a while got
to be known as someone, uh,
in the gangster world.
Uh,
so I read a lot about him and I watched
his movies and was delighted at the
fact, uh, that, uh, uh,
relearning about somebody who I thought
was one thing and he turned out to be a
whole other thing altogether.
Um,
in terms of what is
nature was like, what, uh,
the,
uh,
and then the size of his talent in terms
of the kinds of roles he was capable of
playing as opposed to the ones that he
had in some cases became famous for. Uh,
but I learned about his love of art,
his massive art collection.
I learned about his life in the
theater before all of that, uh,
about his political
affiliations, about, um,
how generous of a spirit he was, how he
would give money to anybody who asked,
um, and, uh, how he was, you know,
one of the friendliest guys in, in the
community, in the Hollywood community.
But he loved him, you
know, so, uh, as the,
uh, all of this political
stuff started heating up,
he kinda got torn in between,
uh,
a lot of different factions in
terms of his own friendships.
Um,
and then he started a showing up
on what they called gray lists,
which were people who were,
uh, being lumped together, uh,
into, uh, onto lists of,
of suppose it communists,
but had not joined the party.
He was very political.
He was a liberal democrat. Um, and,
um,
yeah, he, uh, um, he,
he found himself in a
position that became quite,
quite difficult, um, and went out
of his way to get in front of the,
the Hugh Act Committee to
explain his affiliations to,
to explain where he gave money,
why he gave him money and a otherwise
it seemed as though people just weren't
going to hire him anymore. Yeah. Uh,
so in the end he had to get up there and
say some things that he did not want to
say, and he had set himself that had
it been a different day or, you know,
had he not been under the
stresses that he was under,
he may not have done what he did,
but he did and lived with it.
Uh,
eventually got to go back to work again.
Um,
but he doesn't seem to be one of those
individuals who was lumped together with
those people who were
supposedly, uh, uh, um,
considered those who named names.
He gave them information they already had.
Uh, it's a, he's lived a
fascinating life. Uh, and,
um, you know, I listened to his voice
a lot. I watched those performances,
particularly around the 1947 48 period
in which he had pretty much exhausted
being a leading man and was starting
to venture into the world of,
of uh, getting what was
called character parts. Um,
and,
uh,
and I watched as much as I
could about who he was, uh,
away from the iconic, you
know, cigar chomping gangster.
A lot of people knew him as,
um, and found him to be quite,
um,
area date.
And our script written by John Mcnamara,
uh,
really explores more of that
personal side than it does, um,
the icon that he was known before.
Yeah.
And as you and your character point out,
the blacklists destroyed the careers
of thousands and thousands of people in
Hollywood, most who never had the
opportunity to truly develop a career. Uh,
interestingly, uh, you
know, writers, um, uh,
could do work under an assumed
name started to be very clear.
They went from making large sums
of money to tiny sums of money.
But as you point out,
you can't act under an assumed face.
You have only one
these days. You might be able
to actually though, you know,
with the digital technology, uh, yeah,
he couldn't do it at that time.
That's when it, that's one of the most,
um, compelling parts of the whole Trumbo,
the Hollywood 10 story Wa was,
was Energy Robinson's dilemma.
And it got to that question that we hope
the film puts in front of any audience
member, which is what would you do? What
would you do if you really had no choice?
Trumbo did have a certain kind of a
set of choices which was just cave and
disappear or keep writing. But
other, uh, other keep writing,
but under other names,
uh, actors, directors,
I happen to have a directing teacher
who was one of the Hollywood 10,
Edward Dmytryk, uh, who taught at
USC when I went to film school there,
he was the only non writer,
uh, you know, of the 10, he,
he was put in jail for the same reason,
blacklisted and then decided to come back,
uh,
and name names and he named a few names
who hadn't been known to the committee
supposedly. And, um, uh,
by the time my God to be a student of his,
you could see the, the co
the damage, you know, of the,
just how conflicted he
was as a person need our,
he'd made a whole bunch of films.
He had,
he had made this decision and got work
out of the decision. You got work.
He started to be able to make money again,
we're it all his writer friends, many,
many of them lost their homes,
lost their,
their families in some
cases lost their health.
And then there were even suicides.
So I'm sure there was a kind
of survivor guilt. I mean,
this is just me speculating. I never
really spoke to him in depth about it.
He didn't really like talking
about it for lots of reasons. Um,
but that the, that same dilemma
was similar to a energy Robinson.
There was no choice. There wasn't another
way through it, the way there was for,
uh,
for the writers.
Okay. In your view? Um, you know, I,
I'm actually one of the reasons
you'd do a film like this is to, um,
is to convey that story and
convey the lessons within it. Um,
as I think you pointed out,
um, in the political that
the greatest tool of all his fear.
Yeah. So when you look at this,
yeah, we'll, we actually learn a
lesson. Can this happen? Again,
it's a, it's a really hard question to
answer without speculating, but you,
you do see a pattern in
political propaganda too.
If you want people to conform or do what
you want them to do as opposed to what
they want to do,
the way to intimidate them and in some
cases bullied them is to hurl labels at
them that conjure up fears of
real threats. In this case,
it was totalitarian communism that was
real. Russia had occupied eastern Europe.
There were very deliberate
efforts to by the rush to, uh,
by Soviet Union to extract
secrets of how to build a bomb.
And that's where their
knowledge of the bomb came from,
was spies from an American scientist.
So that was all real.
But by calling someone a
communist, Eh, you know, or, or a,
in this case Trumbo was a comics bike
by calling him a trader and accusing him
of being a puppet of Russia,
then you could neutralize him.
And nowadays it would be, um,
calling someone a, you know, friendly
to terrorism or somehow unamerican uh,
you know, in a, in a world
post nine 11. So it is,
I do fear, feel like, uh, that, uh,
fear is the most useful propagandist
tool and the most useful political
manipulation tool. And you see
in, in today, you still see a,
you know, ridiculous waste of
taxpayers' money, uh, by Congress.
People trying to make
names for themselves,
doing congressional investigations that
lead nowhere. I mean, that, this, the,
the investigation of the queue,
I can lead to nothing.
There no was no one ultimately
charged with any real subversion,
no films pulled out, you know, or even
even, you know, banned or censored.
There was, they couldn't point to any
one particular case. It was just, well,
he might've known somebody
who knew somebody who maybe
had something to do with
that other thing.
It was all hearsay.
And that stuff is easy to manipulate and,
and,
and it does happen today. It happens
in every, in every era. I think. So.
I hope the film just raises your,
raises, people's skepticism,
keeps the conversation going a about
where are we being manipulated, ah,
based on fear as opposed to being a,
you know,
asked to consider anything that's
a genuine threat around us.
And in doing that often the
misuse of labels, you know, the,
the equation of communism who terrorized
totalitarian handle the equation of
being Muslim with being a terrorist. Yeah.
It's so easy to twist these and, and,
and, and use these for,
and they're really bad,
bad ideas that the idea that all Muslims
are terrorists is a great example of
it.
That's a,
that's a kind of bizarre mutated
equivalents that costs people,
you know,
in some cases their lives.
There's some there it can fan
as sort of hate based, uh,
approach to life, you know. Uh, and
so it's such a cynical, a choice too,
to use fear that way. Just to try to
get people to conform or be more like,
you know, you want the world to be. Yeah.
Well let, let's, let's shift it a
touch lighter. Yeah. Sorry. Um, so,
uh, so early you assembled
a marvelous, cashed, uh,
with Trumbo in addition to Michael,
you know, Helen Mirren, Louis C, k e,
John Goodman, Elle fanning. Um,
but also you landed Walter White,
um, another well known gangster, you know,
the beloved Bryan Cranston.
And interestingly,
you're working with him
again on, on Lbj. Um, so,
so what's the deal with that? I mean, is
it about that drugs? Is this, is this,
is this about crystal blue persuaded?
What does that, what's the
attraction? Just a, yeah,
he got me hooked and then I have
to, to, to pay for my habit.
I have to keep casting and foresight. No,
he's um, he's amazing. That's what it is.
It just a,
and he has not just the passion
and depth of someone like Trimble,
but he has the wit and that,
that that's,
it does give me a chance to transition
to something else that goes on in our
film.
There is humor and we have Louis Ck in
the film and we have John Goodman and my,
one of my favorite scenes in
the whole film attacking a,
a union leader who's trying to
pressure him into caving to, uh,
to the House on American activities,
uh, committees, desire to,
to not employ blacklisted people.
Uh,
and it's because so many of these guys
coped with this predicament by being
hilarious. Uh, Trumbo was famously funny,
uh, in, in letters, many,
many letters he wrote from jail to
his family, to his, you know, to,
to Mitzi saying, ego is upper
and go to bed. You know,
like as if he was still there
in the room and, and to enemies.
He called one enemy, one, one, one
producer who had betrayed him, uh,
who was trying to have it both ways, a
political hermaphrodite. I was like, Oh,
I wish I could, you know, Landa,
an insult like that to someone.
And He,
they were all funny.
His own funeral turned into a roast
because his buddies just couldn't help
themselves. Big, give him a hard
time, you know, even in the grave.
And that's the kind of guys they were.
So in it licensed us to,
to be more authentic.
We needed comedy actually.
And even in the midst of all of
this kind of psychological terror,
if you will. Um, there was, there
had to be humor. And so we cast,
uh, you know, a whole people
with a whole range of, of skills.
There's some, um, Edward G. Robinson
has a couple of really great lines.
Uh, when he, when he talks about the
NPA and says they're all fascist,
that they just don't have
that they're all Nazis.
They just don't have the uniforms.
I mean, everyone who's in, in,
in the middle of horrible sort of
crisis and battle can also be funny,
uh,
to cope with it.
Well, let me pursue that notion
of just a little bit further, um,
because you, you have done,
uh, you know, serious films,
films with serious subject matter,
um, and, and obviously, uh,
many films like that. You know, I'm a
big fan of Paul Thomas Anderson Films,
but you know, they're
different. Um, and, and,
and often not accessible,
but I, which makes me wonder,
as you approach a serious subjects,
do you explicitly go after the use of
comedy as a means of making the subject
more approachable?
Well, I don't, I mostly, again,
I just try to have it honor the story and
honor the characters. I'm going to end,
by the way I, I can think of an
exception to what you were just saying.
It using an actress who I worked at the,
um, Julianne Moore in Boogie Nights,
boogie nights is so dark,
it's so twisted and it has some really
funny performances by Bill Macy, uh,
by Julianne Moore and, uh, casting
someone like Julianne to play.
Sarah Palin is a great example because
she gets where the ironies are.
She gets the absurdities and she's playing
them with a complete total commitment
to capturing the essence of that person.
But there is with their, you know,
and I, that's why I cast people like
Michael Stuhlbarg and John Goodman and,
and, and Brian too. But we
have Louis CK plying, you know,
a hardline communists.
And the reason is because we needed
someone to the left of Trumbo, who was,
you know,
had joined the Communist Party during
the war when we were aligned with a
communist superpower.
But we needed someone much who
was actually a good party member,
which was Louis Ck is character.
Whereas Trumbo was not that
great of a party member.
He wasn't that conformist
even to the Communist Party.
So he now you have someone like Louis C
K busting him for being a hypocrite and
for being so full of himself
and, and for, as he says,
talking like every single thing he's going
to say is going to be chiseled into a
rock. You know, that's,
that's why you that,
that they're the actual men themselves
made an obligation to cast funny people
because they were funny
just to be authentic.
Yeah. Um, let me shift a bit. Um,
over the years, my wife and I often joke
when we see a film that start off with,
based on a true story, which is
not the case with trombone. Uh,
we always had to Wikipedia and aero is
to find out that more often than not,
the keyword is based.
Not True. Um, uh, and,
and of course there's been a lot of
discussion about that recently. Uh,
most specifically with the
film Steve Jobs, you know,
Aaron Sorkin and sin in their criticism
of Aaron Sorkin with regard to his,
his take license is license with,
uh,
with that real life
character into a character.
And a lot of people say did
not really exist. So, um,
Michael First, um, again, you
played a real life character
with Edward G. Robinson.
You didn't have the benefit of
spending any time with Edward G.
Robinson since he's long passed,
deceased,
but you also played a real life character
with Andy Hertzfeld in Steve Jobs. So,
you know, from your perspective
as an actor, how do you approach,
how do you approach these roles that
are obviously not based on fictional
characters? I mean, what's your approach
to, to the verse similitude I mean, is it,
is it impressionistic? Is it
realistic? What do you strive for
truth, however, right. I
can get to it, I suppose.
Uh, yeah, I mean,
my experience on Steve Jobs was unique
in that it was the very first time I got
to meet the person that I
was going to be playing, um,
uh, at a different time in
his life. I'll be it, uh,
or three different times in his life.
But it was a wonderful opportunity for
me to observe him, to asking questions,
to absorb as much of
his energy as I could.
And he was free with his time and was
very honest with all of his experiences
regarding Mr Jobs. And, um, he
couldn't have been kinder to me and,
and more generous.
Uh,
so that was a very positive experience and
really it's my job to be, you know, to,
to not judge anything, just to absorb
it and try to reflect that back,
I guess.
And taking into account as well the text
that I am given to tell that story with
Mr Sorkin's dialog. You know, there's,
there's no improvisation in terms of,
you know,
might participating in what
that story might be. It's,
it's there for me and,
uh,
it's my job to give it truth,
give it life.
Uh, uh, interpret it. Um,
in this case it was a much more sort
of a collaborative process because I
became,
and often it's the case with telling
the story of somebody who actually lived
you.
I find that I have to become the authority
on that character because then nobody
else has time in out to say,
well, actually, you know,
he did this or he did that.
I have to know as much as I can.
Uh, in the case of boardwalk empire,
I got to know as much as I could about
Arnold Rothstein and, uh, and uh,
was able to, you know, throw
opportunities. It's just
about options, you know,
say this happened, you know, if you want
to use it, that's great. In this case,
it's not a story about necessarily
about Edward G. Robinson.
Our focus is Dalton Trumbo, so I offer
as much as I can. If it's helpful, great.
If it's not a let it go,
you know, it's, uh, I,
uh,
I try to offer as much as I can.
I don't want to become a burden and I
don't want to overstep my boundaries,
but I feel like at least it's,
it's out there as an opportunity,
as something to, to share it, to
help with. Yeah. And by the way, I,
I happened to know Andy and I know he
very much appreciated your, your, uh,
uh, um, the way you played him. I'm
glad. I'm glad. I think that's the,
the thing is, is to, to be authentic,
to find an essential truth.
Um,
someone asked me, uh, when we were
screening in Toronto, you know,
how much of the film is not true?
And I said all of it,
you realize they're actors, right? You
realize that he's not an energy Robinson.
He's interpreting it. Richard Robinson.
It's not history. As John McNamara says,
it's a story about history.
And it is,
I think a little bit of a distraction
to focus so heavily when you're,
when you're watching a movie that's
derived from historical thing on all the
factual, you know, uh, uh,
accuracy. Things like, wait,
that didn't happen on that day.
That happened on a different day or that
that though, you know, this is their, um,
you know, they changed the names of that
character. They did this, that's not the,
the restaurant where this happened, that
happened at a different restaurant. Well,
if you are so slavish to
that level of accuracy,
you would have had to tell this film and
you'd have to sit in a theater for 13
years to watch it because we condensed it.
That didn't really happen in two hours.
It happened.
So the point is not to be facetious
about it because I do think there is
validity and comparing a truce,
true story to history.
That's,
there is something because you learn about
the storytelling from the differences,
but to dismiss a film,
which happens a lot these days and
some great films recently because it's
somehow took license. I think
if it, if the license is,
gets you further from the truth of the,
essentially the essence of what happened
or the essence of who the people were,
that's a really legitimate criticism.
But if the film,
as we tried to do is trying so hard to
get it right in terms of what it was
about, what every character cared about,
um, who they were as people, what,
what,
what their dilemmas where and there,
then I think there is,
it would be ashamed to say no film is
valid if it's not perfectly adherent to
the, to the facts. Otherwise you
have to throw out Shakespeare.
You have to throw out.
There's never been a film,
never in the history of filmmaking.
And I would argue never in the
history of playwriting either,
that has been so faithful to the
facts that it couldn't be, uh,
you know, uh, um, you know, that
it couldn't be ripped apart.
And when you started comparing it to
what really happened, I think that,
I think that's very valid. Um, but it
is an interesting, interesting question.
We see this in the world of
politics. I mean, Cheney, for
instance, Dick Cheney was,
you know, the common technique. He was
the leak something to the New York Times,
right? And then three days later when
it was reported by the New York Times,
he'd point as reported in the New York
Times where he would actually manage to
transmute ally and too,
but I think there's a big difference
between claiming something is factually
accurate and and versus saying this
is a, an interpretation. For example,
we use a lot of archival footage in
the film to say this actually happened.
There's real Ronald Reagan sitting at a
table. There's uh, you know, the real,
the real room where this took place,
the walls of our set we're at,
we shot on green screen and he lack
hearings and went to DC and shot stills of
the actual walls of the actual room.
All right,
so we went to that level of accuracy
and then I do this trick I Dolly and on
Bryan Cranston as Trumbo intercut with
real footage of the real hearings.
Now our footage is made to look black
and white to match as if some in some
weird reality.
Bryan Cranston's Trumbo is there at the
hearings in 1947 that you've just seen
actual footage from and I move the
edges of the screen out to the full one
widescreen format. I dissolve to color,
right? Is Bryan Cranston and saying,
I'm not going to answer yes or no because
you know, to answer some questions,
yes or no,
you'd have to be a moron or a slave.
And we push in and put the sound
into the wide, the wide speakers,
you know the surround sound,
and I'm saying this is now
officially not history.
This is a construct.
This is an interpretation.
It's an actor who I've
craftily tried to blend in and,
and take you there,
but remind you,
be skeptical and be a
participant and ask what's real,
what's not. That's part
of the deal here. You're,
you're being asked to take this as
an interpretation and go with it.
But I'm reminding you that I'm
going to mess with you. And that's,
I think that that's different from saying,
know what I'm saying is the facts and
you should base every decision in our
political system or whether we go
to war on, on this claim that I've,
that I'm due to it. Does that make sense?
Absolutely. And you know, I mean look,
you start from the basis
that what is truth?
I mean so much is perception and not,
yeah.
I mean there are very few things that we
can easily label is binary, true or not.
But then you ask, you know, Mitzi, uh, and
Nikki, you know what's true about this?
And there were lots of debates about some,
some licensed we took
and they were very valid.
And some in some cases they got us close
so much closer to the truth cause they
gave the details of what really
felt like to be in that family.
But then they bow had to have said the
way Brian portrayed their father was so
close to some essential
truth of who he was.
That it was disconcerting sometimes
and even surreal. And that's,
I think that's the greatest compliment
to how Brian came at it, was that he was,
he was that committed to the truth.
And I really think Michael's,
that story of Edward G.
Robinson is so heartbreaking to me.
It was so important to,
and I,
he did go so much deeper than I
had time to go and each character,
so he would bring an idea, various cool,
simple detail that I love was that he,
Mac, John Mcnamara had it in
the thing that this first real,
the film within our film that goes
wrong in the middle of a take,
he flubs a line and he knew
from reading about about energy.
Robinson Robinson would never blow a line,
but he was terrible with props.
So we put in there that he,
he has a prop gun that he's supposed
to be super threatening with,
but in a weird gesture, the, he
mishandles the profit flies up,
the bullets fly out of the gun and land
all over the stage. And it was, it was,
it was so cool to know that that
was an essentially true part of who,
who Robinson was. Whereas what we
were going to have him do wasn't,
so we went for the
authentic thing, uh, as,
as close as we could and it just
enriched the story. And that's what,
that's what happens when you're working
with such a great actor who is so
committed to some,
to the,
to the nuances and the details that that
give something a life to it. That's,
that's, that was amazing. Well,
by the way, interestingly in my,
my wife not with Brian
refers to him as dad,
which is a little younger than both
of them. They seem doctor Freud,
exactly an answer to that.
So Michael,
let's switch that around again
because you've worked with,
with many filing directors and
imagine all of them have very,
very different approaches to
how they work with actors. Um,
do you select directors as carefully
as you select role? I wish.
What do you want? What do
I wanted to direct your
question? I was the answer that
no, I mean honestly it changes from
job to job because sometimes you can,
you can just know it in the deepest
part of who you are as to what a moment
should be about or what
a character is like.
And other times you might
have no idea. So, uh,
in some cases I want to be a collaborator
and absolutely share every thought and
idea with a director and to say, what
should we do together? What can we do?
Help me be on the outside,
help guide me through what I'm doing,
cause I can't look at myself while I'm
doing this or I don't want to look at it
while I'm doing it. Um,
uh, uh, and in some cases,
I know a lot of actors don't
want any direction at all.
They just want to get up there
and do their thing and you know,
you can cut it how you're going
to cut it. Uh, it's, it's,
it's often described as
a director's medium. Um,
and uh, I agree with that to
a great extent. However, uh,
depending upon the length of a shot,
you know,
if you shoot something
for a very long time,
it depends upon what it is you're
shooting. So it's, it's, uh,
you know,
I like to think of the collaboration
with the director as a collaboration,
uh,
as opposed to there being any,
a sense of hierarchy. Uh, um,
and like I sort of inferred a,
it would be great if I could choose
which directors I wanted to work with.
In my case it's been
just dumb luck honestly,
to get to work with the folks
I've gotten to work with. Um,
and really just trying to
make the best of my situation.
Great.
Well,
we're at Google and we can't have a
conversation at Google without having some
question and related to
technology. Um, and you know,
obviously we're a company born of the
Internet and the Internet has had a
massive impact on how all forms of,
of media of being
distributed and accessed. Um,
we talked once a about this
and you mentioned for instance,
how dramatically different the
financial structures and frankly,
compensation was based on say,
a studio financed and distributed
film versus an independent film.
And we're now potentially moving into
an era where there could be such a thing
as a self distributed film. Um,
what are your thoughts on that?
I mean, I, I know you're a very tech
savvy person, but how do you look at that?
I think, well, I, you know,
I think most artists would answer
and say the more you could, uh,
connect directly to the audience.
You know, I was very envious of, uh,
listening to Louis Ck last
night. Talk about the way he, um,
you know, comedians work
their business when they're,
when they're working at the scale
he's working at where you go,
they go and rent a place, you think
of, Oh, I'm played Carnegie Hall,
Carnegie Hall. So someone at Carnegie
Hall invited him in to come in and put a,
or Madison Square gardens. But, uh,
he like all comedians and I think most
musical acts to go and rent the space and
then pay the overhead and pay.
But the,
the world of how it's done and all
the business is theirs. They own it.
And film has always been
owned by the studios,
every aspect of it,
including the copyright,
which is always astonishing to me
that unlike in theater, uh, you know,
are the writers get to keep
their copyright and licensing.
The studios have set it
up early on that they,
because they were the capitol
and the, the, the, the,
you needed the big buildings
and the big machines to do it.
They owned everything and
that worked out great.
And I think the studio system,
you know, made, has made so much,
so many great films. I've, I worked
almost all in the studio process.
I think in the comedy world in particular,
they're very good at it.
But I'm so glad to see
other models kicking in. Uh,
a,
I've had a great time working at Hbo.
I think their model is really
interesting where they're just, you know,
not we can box office oriented or
not, uh, you know, ratings oriented.
But the new thing that Netflix and Amazon
and Google and apple to some extent to
where it's, it's a whole different, uh,
more I think more direct shot
to the consumer is promising.
And the, as the technology
simplifies, as you can see,
as you can actually shoot a
feature film on an iPhone now, um,
and cut it on an iPhone if you want, you
can cut but it's easier to use a laptop.
Uh,
you,
you may or may not still need to go
through such a gigantic bureaucratic,
um, sometimes, sometimes artistically
controlling organization to,
to speak what you,
to tell the story you want to tell.
That's thrilling. That is reeling
because it will become more like,
I'm just going to sit down and write a
novel today or, or a short story. You can,
you can, you know, my kids
are, my, my one son is,
is making short movies and he can
post them on youtube, you know,
and they're there. And if you work
it out through, through whatever,
you can get a little piece
of the financial action, you
know, just, just yourself,
just you uploading it to
things. So I think that's, wow,
that's thrilling. And I, I see it as
the future, you know, it really is.
It's happening, but I mean, it's going
to really start happening now, uh,
in a very short, short term future,
I suspect to you, what do you think?
I think without question, I
mean, we have seen, you know,
as we've seen the internet evolve.
I mean,
the one thing that is clear is we're
seeing vastly more expression from vastly
more voices than we've ever seen in the
history of civilization. You know? Yeah.
Stop.
It's new. And News is, that
was the first to go. I mean,
you can suddenly be your own news outfit.
Precisely. Yeah. And that's,
uh, you know, as I often say,
it's the back to the first amendment
again. It's a, you know, you can,
it's easy to look at the
Internet, uh, you know,
in the United States and think of it as
the first amendment come to life in that
ability to have that access to
distribution. And now, you know,
the first amendment guarantees
you to write, to express yourself.
It doesn't guarantee an audience who's
going to listen to or quality or quality.
And that is certainly true in
spades with the Internet. Uh,
I don't suggest that the Internet is the
solution to all things as I often point
out. It has value, but it
doesn't have values. Uh, it's,
it's all what we make of it.
That someday some other
longer conversation about
how news is evolved and how
under the fairness doctrine and
when there were three networks,
somehow news was so, uh, you know, so,
but it was controlled and we didn't know
how much you filtered it was, but it,
you know,
was it better back then with Walter
Cronkite and Huntley and Brinkley or,
you know, did it ha, you know,
has it, has it evolved to a,
it's hard to tell when you
watch CNN and Fox and, you know,
it's hard to tell if they've got
better. So it's a really, uh,
it's a really interesting thing
of, of uh, yeah, what, what, um,
what the democratization of,
of our media has accomplished.
And I suspect that a jury
that will always please
be out. Yeah. And we never know.
I mean, cable, I, you know, I was,
I was there at the beginnings
of that and you know,
cable television is actually proven to
be a rather remarkable disappointment for
the purposes of journalism.
It's turned into nothing more
than a continuous sequence
of confrontational chat
shows. Yeah. Um, uh, you know,
hopefully we'll see that.
And I think we are seeing will evolve
hopefully. Yeah. So promising for awhile.
Yeah,
it is.
I mean we're seeing great investigative
journalism done by small outfits that
are willing Pulitzer prizes.
On the other hand,
I would suggest that the birther
movement would have not taken hold.
We're not to the fact that you can find
hundreds of sites that will back up
people's fears and disbeliefs.
Right. So as you point out, you know,
free expression doesn't guarantee quality.
It simply guarantees the opportunity
to put your voice out there.
And I think the challenge for all of us
in society now is to try to figure out
how do we sift through that to find a
way to separate to wit from which I have,
which I think is cool about some of the
stuff you guys are up to that, that is,
that is the p the pickle. And I think,
I do think it's a healthy thing,
but it's going to be very chaotic for a
while, still longer. Um, um, before it's,
before it becomes, as, as it
lives up to the promise. Well,
I just want to thank you usually for
coming and spending the time here and, uh,
um, uh, for Googlers here for Googlers
every word watching the live stream,
and we'll have that video available on
Youtube for others to look at as well.
Okay, great. Yeah, thanks. Thank
you very much for having me.
Thank you.